Victoria is next in Spokane Washington
hi Victoria how are you hi Dave thank
you for taking my call
sure what's up I have a situation I have
just got step one done and I'm working
on step two
good I have medical issue that came up
I'm like okay I'm gonna save up because
I know it's coming up and save up for it
I don't have to hit my emergency fund
which year you always say hey save up
full big thing so that's why I'm doing
and I just called my student loan
company to get my income based payment
set up for the next year and they just
told me that it goes from eighty-five
dollars a month to three hundred and
twenty-one one so because apparently my
income is over their limit and I'm like
well what about trying to pay off other
stuff you know train did well I don't
care they don't care about that
obviously they just have a system and
what is your income it's about just
under 3000 months okay and you are on
income based repayment before at what
level of income at about 25 okay 25
hundred a month yeah 25 hundred a month
okay so you went from thirty three
thousand to thirty six thousand and now
they're saying you don't qualify what's
the balance on your student loan all of
them together is about just under 130 so
oh my goodness what is your degree in
are you're a doctor or lawyer I wish I
went to a for-profit college but just
closed and you got a degree out so I'm
trying to work on getting those paid off
yeah your degrees in what I have a
bachelor's in information system
security and the missile shoots and
computer electronics technology okay
and why can you not make more than
$36,000 a year if you have a bachelor's
in
and information security you already
make it double that the degree the
school I went to is fraud pretty much
fraud dresses out of it you barely had
to do any of the school work to pass the
car so you don't really know what you're
doing
pretty much oh that sucks yeah okay um
and the student loans were owed to whom
um most were to Sallie Mae about just
under 80,000 BOE
and then I have a another company peeps
for the rest of it I'm pretty sure that
if the company is a for-profit company
running the school and it goes broke
that the student loans are forgiven I
want you to check on that yeah I'm
currently working on checking on that so
um yeah because you've got a mess on
your hands otherwise so yeah we've got
to get your income up long-term you mean
we got to work on your career and
everything else but um that that's a
long-term fix that's not a short-term
fix and it doesn't help you with a $300
jump either so who is it this telling
you that Sallie Mae or Peaks
well Sallie Mae navient okay you know
that would make sense
but uh you know so what I would do is
just go back to them and say I'm not
going to pay you anything right now you
can just put me and default or put me in
hardship deferral one of the two because
I can't I don't have the money to do
this right now and begin to negotiate
with them but I'm also going to really
go to work on this whole thing I can't
remember the details of the plan
Victoria but I don't remember if it's
just for the private sector section of
the loans or if it included Sallie Mae
or not but there is a in the back of my
mind tickling back there and I don't
remember the details so I want you to
really go dig into it there is a
regulation law that is bouncing around
back in the history of my brain
somewhere and I can't find the file
right now that says something like that
student loans are forgive
upon a company going broke that caused
you to get the student loans and it
keeps you from being held hostage to
these scam schools which is obviously
what happened here so I want you to look
into that a little bit more and try to
find the details on that I don't know
the details but I just remember that
there's something along those lines out
there and so dig into that because
that's going to be one of your best
hopes there is to get that so hey thanks
for the call I wish I could be more help
I wish I had a magic one for your kid oh
that's you got a mess on your hands
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider rinsing right over
here or click the link in the
description below